[موسيقى]
الاستعاده الساعه الحيويه بيعتمد على
تنظيمها اثناء الصيام بحيث ان كلما زاد
اختلال الساعه الحيويه
بنحتاج وقت اطول بعد الافطار او بعد
انتهاء الشهر الكريم لاستعاده بشكل طبيعي
بعض النصائح اللي بنقدمها ان احنا نحاول
ننام في مواعيد منتظمه ان احنا نحاول ناخد
اكتر من دورتين في النوم اثناء اليوم
فبالتالي يتم تقسيم النوم بحيث لا تقل
فتره النوم عن اربع ساعات في كل دوره وعدم
تجنب او عدم الاقتراص بعدم الاكل او تجنب
الاكل عدم الافراط في الاستخدام السكريات
وعدم الافراط في تناول
المواد المنبهه المحتويه على الكافيين
ممارسه الرياضه بشكل مستمر او بشكل منتظم
بتؤدي لتنظيم الساعه الحيويه وسرعه
استعاده
تجنب ممارسه الرياضه خلال ساعتين قبل
النوم فبالتالي اذا حابين نمارس رياضه
بيكون قبل النوم ساعتين على الاقل
[موسيقى]
لتحسين جوده النوم بنحتاج ان احنا نبتدي
من اول ساعات اليقظه ان احنا نحددها في
موعد ثابت وتكون مرتبطه اكتر
ببدايه اليوم او ظهور الشمس ومرتبطه باشعه
الشمس اللي بتؤدي لبعض التغيرات الحيويه
والكيميائيه داخل الجسم منها افراز هرمون
الكورتيزون هرمون النمو وتنظيم هرمون
الميلاتونين اللي بيساعد على تنظيم النوم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات